i felt like
defeated
when i lay down
because i just was hoping that you
wouldn't
want to have sex with me
and then
they um but he did so but i just
i think like i thought in my own mind
that
this was it now
[Music]
kate can you tell me what was your
childhood like
um
well my my childhood actually wasn't
that bad um
my mom and dad divorced when i was seven
but it didn't seem to affect us that
badly and we kind of like
um
had a decent childhood really um it was
a bit boring because it was a
countryside
but um
nothing really eventful happened um
when i was younger
um i moved out of my mom's house when i
was 18
and i moved into
the ymca which is like a supported
living accommodation for um
teenagers it was sort of between 18 and
16 and 25 but most people were around
the age of 18. i was trying to like i
don't know i was being like
typical um
i don't know what you see on tv when you
want to be a friendly neighbor i was
like um
let me bake cakes for my neighbors
so that's how that's kind of how i met
um that's how i met william so we kind
of like um formed a little friendship
group and we we would hang out together
well i was i was warned by some staff in
the ymca that um william had some like
unsavory friends
and um i actually didn't know
what they meant by that he introduced me
to one of his friends
and that was ali sultan
you don't know what you're looking at
when you look at when you see someone
dangerous i don't know like um i was so
i was so new that i didn't
realize um
how dangerous they were i just saw them
as like the same way that i'd see
anybody else from from college
um because they weren't they weren't
like really old or anything they were
like the same age as well almost the
same age as me maybe um
maybe ali was like 20 and i was 18.
there was like slight
indications of something
brewing um like
um every now and then if i if i saw if i
saw
members of their group um like across
the road or something like that they'd
make like [ __ ] symbols to me um with
their mouths by sticking their tongue um
in their cheek
and um i'd just be like
that's weird like weirdos
and um and then there was talk of this
guy getting one of them getting out of
prison
um i heard a bunch of rumors about what
he'd done to end up in prison
he'd randomly
walk past somebody in the church yard
and beat them up and
broken their jaw um so he'd gone to
prison for gbh
um
and he was in he was in prison for a
year and a half and he was just getting
out that weekend um is sort of
when he
first like
came to knock on my door um
and i looked through my
little spy hole that i've got and it was
like it was like a little kid it was
like an eight-year-old or something
um so i opened the door to see what the
kid wanted
um
and um as soon as i opened the door the
kid had vanished like i never actually
saw him
and um
shamil had put his foot he was like
hiding behind the wall
um so that i couldn't see through him
through the spy hole before it opened
the door and he put his foot in the door
and started to push his way in
and i was like really strongly trying to
push him out
um and i was pushing him out and i was
pushing him out and um
william was shouting to me is that
chamil um
and i said yeah um
thinking that maybe he'd come and help
me push him out um but instead william
said just let him in
um
so
because william said let him in i let go
of the door which i really wish that i
hadn't done now
um
but i don't think it would have made a
difference i think it would have gone
anyway
he came in he made some excuse to get
rid of
william
he said that shazia was waiting for him
around the corner
um at his flat because he lived on the
opposite side of the building to me
and he went into
and then
william just left
and then all of a sudden i was alone
with shamil
and um
that was you know that was quite
horrible he started circling me um
and um he's like he was like quite
muscular because he'd been like working
out at the gym
um and he wanted me to know that
um and um
he sort of grabbed hold of me and put
his arms around my neck um
and not in a not in a like i'm in a
strangle you way but um in sort of like
what he felt was
like a sexual way and i was trying to
push him off me but actually when i
tried to push him off me he was
tightening his grip and then it felt
like
he's gonna strangle me if i
if i resist
so um
he was like trying to kiss me and he was
kissing me on the
chest and he was kissing me trying to
kiss me on the lips and i was like
moving my face out of the way and so he
was just kissing my cheek um and um
i was trying to say that
i didn't like i didn't want him to kiss
me and um i was trying to say that i was
in a relationship i was trying to come
up with like reasons why
he
shouldn't be doing what he's doing um
because i guess he was making me feel
like
i don't want to wasn't a good enough
reason not to do it
um
but he
just behaved in a way like he was
completely ignoring me as if he didn't
hear what i was saying
well um that that was the first time i
was raped
um and
i tried to use
i tried to use
um
what do you call it um like negotiation
to get out of it but none of none of
that actually worked
um
so it was like the first time that i
kind of regretted what what i'd done
um and was it my fault or was it was it
his fault like did i not did i not um
because i'd negotiated rather than
because i had well i had directly said
no and then negotiated but like had i
not been clear that um that that's not
what i wanted
um
so
um i'd spend the week after that kind of
in my head totally in my head like
running over running like everything
that had happened like was it was it me
was it would did i
was it him did he have learning
disability
you know all these things like did he
not realize did he literally not hear me
because he didn't respond and so when i
was
saying no so didn't he hear me
um
and then
everything else happened so quickly
after
that first rape
that um i was like i was still in shock
from the first rape it was like an
ongoing i describe it as like an ongoing
shock like you have shocked like at the
time that it's happening
and where you have like the file flight
but then
i feel like i was like in the days
every day after that
sorry let's can we stop for a second
sure take your time don't worry about us
so after that first rape happened did
you consider telling anyone police
family friends anyone
i didn't know what to do at the time
and
one of the things in my head
was that i just wanted to pretend that
it didn't happen
or
maybe
i could
learn to like him
and then
it was just like normal sex like so it
wouldn't be
it wouldn't hurt it wouldn't be abs
upsetting it'd be okay
like because like other times
other times i'd had sex like
it was it that's all it is like it's
just a it's just an action it's just sex
so what is it how to feel so bad
it was my it was the week of all my
final exams and um i've just been raped
at the weekend and i'd got
five exams that week one of one of the
exams i just went into and
it was a psychology exam and i just
couldn't think um couldn't like my head
was just
empty um because i was still in shock so
um
i'd sort of confided in a in the college
counsellor and she like encouraged me to
talk to the police and she said even if
you don't
want to press charges
then um
you could just tell the police for
like information
um so that if he hurt someone else then
um they've got it on record that he had
hurt you as well
she um contacted the police for me
and um they made an appointment for the
end of that week to see them
when i was back home
ali sultan and knocked on my door
he brought a friend with him
and
he wanted me to
give them both all oral sex and
i couldn't fight anymore
and i just
feel like
i said no but i just gave up really
easily because i just
it was scary now like um ally was scary
anyway and um
and then like
after i'd been raped by shamil um
all all the other stuff they were doing
became really scary like like the
[ __ ] symbols that i've been ignoring
before that um then became like really
sinister and
intimidating and um scary
and
i guess that's when i realized that it
was
real
so by um by the saturday that i saw the
police i had already been raped again
twice
so i didn't but i didn't i didn't
realize at that time that i'd been
raped by ali sultan because
i thought i'd given up and
i didn't think that again not like felt
like i wasn't fighting for myself enough
so
i thought like mistakenly that that was
consensual act
um and i just felt really guilty about
it and i didn't realize that i could
even report that
the policewoman that i spoke to
actually was nice but she
had to seek advice from like her
superior and
when the advice came back it was um
if you don't want him to be arrested
then you have to say is consensual
um
because if you say that it's rape then
we have to arrest him so they got me to
write a statement to say that
um it was consensual sex but i regretted
it and i felt pushed into it
and i said that i
i'd said that i didn't want him to be
arrested
um
because i was
scared of the repercussions
um from
him or from his family members because
everybody knows where i live
how did it progress from there the abuse
so i was raped by um
ali on the wednesday
and his friend
and
then the next week um i was raped by
another one
um
i was william's friend
and um
he had
they all like refused to use protection
as well
and
by that point completely like lost
control
over
who i had sex with
and
it changed the way that i viewed sex as
well and i became kind of like afraid of
sex and i didn't realize at the time
like what what the rules of consent
really were so um i blamed myself for a
lot of it um
and that prevented me like going back to
the police
i think especially because
the police had like
implied that what happened with shamil
was consensual so
if that was if even that wasn't rape
then
the other times weren't rape either so
i didn't even
i didn't even think that that anything
was wrong that they were doing anything
wrong i thought it was my fault i
thought that i'd made like some massive
mistakes
in the way that i'd conducted myself and
i thought that
i
like had given myself a reputation
and
that i deserved it because i'd made
those
i i'd set this up for myself kind of
thing
sorry
and then kind of um after that i like
literally
i couldn't get away from them i don't
know whether they'd like taken a picture
of me or whether they'd like pointed me
out um to people but like strangers that
i didn't know would come up to me in the
street if i was like
with my friends or if i was going to the
shop i even had one incident where um
these guys pulled up in their car and
they they said a uk and i was like how
do they know who i am there was like
four of them in the car
um and i didn't but none of them were
any of the guys that i'd ever met so
um and um they were saying oh we've
we've heard that you're that your oral
skills are very good and um
so i knew that they must know
ali because ali was coming around
regularly
um and um
sometimes
they didn't like they didn't say that
they knew me um
and
it looked random so it almost felt like
every every man um was trying to um
get me to have sex with them
and it just
made it
really difficult to
um
associate like the difference in in like
what was a good man and what was a bad
man
it was the
kind of constant um
the constant
reminders the oldest [ __ ]
and there was another time where um
i was tricked into
going to a party
the guy kind of like given me a lot of
false reassurance he'd been saying
things like i'm not um
i'm not like the other guys
um
um so i went to this party with him and
um
he
pulled me this um
very large glass of vodka with lemonade
it was like half and half you know like
one of those tall glasses and it was
half and half
half of the glass with vodka and i was
like looking at the glass thinking oh my
goodness i can't drink that
if i'd have drank the amount that he was
trying he'd poured me
then i would have been paralytic by the
end of the glass
so this is about four months into the
abuse and
i was being raped regularly um
like
sometimes two or three times a week
and then sometimes more than one man in
a day
and
i was feeling
very um like
partly upset with myself and secondly i
was trying to
take control when i didn't have any can
when i felt that i didn't have any
control so
i
sometimes was like seeking out
sex myself so that i could have sex
consensually
and
i was trying to
make active decisions on like whether i
was wanted to sleep with somebody or not
and then i was trying to like
differentiate the difference between
sex and rape and
men that i wanted to sleep with the men
that i didn't want to sleep with so i
had thought to myself that like
i'll sleep with him
um so he kind of like led me into a room
and um
wanted me um and then like i was gonna
consent to sex with him um but then
when it actually came to doing it
um he
actually
forcibly
anally raped me
and um i wasn't expecting it
it was extremely painful
and
i
tried to crawl away but he
managed to pin me um
like pin me with my head against the
headboard and
um
pin me in one place or i couldn't get
out so
i just had to
persevere with it until he'd finished
um and then
and then he when he got off me he um
like humiliated me by um
inviting all his friends in to the room
um to look at me
and
i was naked i was embarrassed um
he
comes he comes out afterwards and shows
all um shows his friends the blood on
the condom afterwards
i thought um
i want to put my clothes on where are my
clothes
and i found i started i found my
underwear and i started putting my
underwear back on
and i started putting my trousers back
on
and um
a guy sat next to me and put his arm
around me and he said why are you
getting dressed and then i thought no
like like
someone someone else wants to have sex
with me after that i thought no i can't
do this so
i just i didn't even know what what to
say but i just ignored him and like
carried on putting my clothes on um
and then i and then when i got dressed i
tried to just leave and um
he grabbed holden like
the guy that had taken me to the party
he grabbed hold of me and he said
why are you trying to leave like come
back into the party like everything's
fine
after all of that like i had to go back
into like the main area of the party and
then that was really humiliating because
everyone knew what had happened
and um everyone was there and then like
people men were talking to me in a
different way as well like um every man
like was taking it in turns to like come
and sit next to me and try and flirt
with me to try and get me into the
bedroom
one one man um
who sat down and spoke to me um
took the sort of rou of like trying to
um
befriend me and get me to trust him and
saying oh you know he shouldn't have
done that that was really bad
um
and he told me a couple of things about
him like that he he always does this to
women um and that some girls come out
come out of the room crying and
screaming
and um
sometimes you hear screams coming from
the room
um
while he's in there with them
when he was saying that there was girls
screaming in the room he was laughing
about it
he made out that like the girls deserved
it for some reason you know like he was
punishing them for something that they'd
done
um
and his friend that guy was like
justifying it in some way
um
and then like he he said like i don't
know what you're doing here like a girl
like you shouldn't be here
um
this is a sex party and everybody like
takes it in turns look at these other
girls that were here um there were there
were two other women there they they
were actually older than me um so i
didn't really think anything of it but
they were very drunk as well
um
i'll take you home he said but then um
then he didn't he didn't take me home
straight away he wanted to have sex with
me first
um
and i kind of thought to myself like if
i just have sex with one more person
then that's still better than having to
have sex with all of them
um
i can't believe that like
somebody would want to have sex with me
after i just been raped
and um
i didn't
i didn't say i didn't say no but i
didn't say yes either i just didn't say
anything
he just like led me into the bedroom and
sat me down on the bed and
pushed me down so that i lay down
and i just no words were like exchanged
at all i just didn't say anything and i
just felt like
you know like um
i felt like
defeated
when i lay down because i just was
hoping that you wouldn't
want to have sex with me
and then
they um but he did so but i just
i think like i thought in my own mind
that
this was it now
it did take me home in the end
how did you manage to escape all of this
abuse with a tougher gang
i think there was
probably
about 13 men
in total before i
managed to escape
um
so within that like four month period um
yeah i'd
been raped by 13 men
so i came up with all these different
ways um
of like dealing with
the situation i was in and one of them
was that if i could go back to college
for another year
then i know it doesn't make sense but in
you know for an 18 year old it was like
the only thing i could think of um then
most of the time i would be out because
i would be studying so like i just
wanted to keep myself busy out of the
house so that they couldn't
um uh
they couldn't knock on the door and i'd
be in like doing nothing
so i um so i went up to college and i
was like i want to go back for another
year
this is like some i don't know one of
the two is she said
go and over to the student advisor and
she'll find you a university course
so i sat with a student advisor she was
like what do you want to do and like we
we um
came up with like brainstormed a couple
of courses and um this was september by
that time
uh we looked at the list of
universities and you know one thing i
said was i don't want to go to
birmingham university and i don't want
to go to wolverhampton university
because both of those universities were
too close in my mind
and if i went to any of the either of
those universities i thought
they'll come and get me
they'll come and get me from telford the
next one was um anglia ruskin which was
in essex i didn't even i was thinking
how far away is essex um when we had a
look it was like 140 miles and i thought
140 miles they're not going to come 140
miles to get me and then by the 26th of
september i'd
moved out and i was there and it was my
first day of of uni
um so it all happened so quickly because
it was like the 4th of september when i
sat down with the student advisor and
before that i had no idea that i would
end up at university i didn't tell
anyone i was going i didn't even tell i
didn't tell william didn't tell anyone
in their mind like i mean as far as they
as far as they like
saw or knew anything like one day i was
there and then the next day i was gone
um
and i've moved out and everything
because i just moved out in one day um
unfortunately like i was
abused all the way up until the day i
left
when you went to the union did you feel
like it was freedom
um
yeah a lot i felt like um
i felt i guess um i guess it gave me
like a bit of a sense of um
like i felt religious about it i felt
like god had like literally
picked me up out of
the middle of hell and
put me at university like in one day
um
and i felt a bit um
like the whole thing was a bit surreal
like uh
one day i was in a in a lot of trouble
in a really bad place and then the next
minute i was absolutely fine
and um
i i i did struggle emotionally a bit
because everyone was really nice to me
and i didn't
feel like i deserved it
um
i felt
like
i had a secret and that if people
actually knew like who i was
it made me feel um
different to everyone else so it was
quite um difficult um to get on
with people not like that i was falling
out with people but that like
um i just felt different
um so i really did struggle to like make
friends
later on um
when i'm trying to have like consensual
sex like i'd get flashbacks
of the first time that i'd done that
position so
it would
like make it upsetting to have sex
and
when um i would want us i would want i
wouldn't want to ruin the
experience for the guy so i just
um i just like ignore the flashback that
i had and just like carry on
um but yeah they wouldn't
you know men don't like to think that
you're thinking about someone
someone else
and they'd probably
like
be really upset if they thought i was
thinking about rape
so
i would just ignore it and just carry on
and i wouldn't let it ruin it
um it took years um until like that
stopped happening
sorry
it's absolutely okay
we have time
how many men were involved in that with
abuse in the birmingham gang
i mean i i counted um i counted 70 while
i was like going through
um the worst of it
how did you manage to break away from
all of that
um
i just i tried my best not to see them
um and
i tried to pick
like
honest activities over
like i don't know how to describe it
like i tried to pick like good
activities over negative activities so
like i'll try to pick friends that i
could go to coffee with
and go
to a coffee shop with them or go
shopping with them rather than spending
time with friends where i would end up
like smoking weed or doing drugs or
having sex
um
and um
i tried to
you know if my family were inviting me
out
or if there was a trip to a theme park
or something like that i would pick that
over
um going to spend time with the gank
and um
i tried not to drink any alcohol
um i i did drugs for
about a year um
and then i because i felt so guilty
about the drugs i was taking and like
made me feel like a really bad person
um and it probably was really terrible
for my mental health as well um i only
did
the like only went back to the gang
in birmingham when i was like having a
weak moment and that's like how i would
describe it um
and um
i did a bunch of things to try and stop
myself having weak moments like um
i changed my number all the time so that
men weren't able to continue contacting
me and then tempting me back or trying
to convince me back
um
because i think that
part of the grooming that i'd suffered
like meant that
um
things like sex pests and um
sexual harassment and pressure was like
it was much easier to get me to
comply like i found it really difficult
to get out of it was easily manipulated
apparently that is a good tactic as well
so um it's something that um
the police advise and it's something
that um sometimes um
uh sort of charities um advice to to
help you like um get rid of the get rid
of gangs and
where any of your abusers ever brought
to justice
um yeah so um i reported it again
in 2010
and um
the police took it much more seriously
than they did last time
the reason i reported it is because i
got to like my third year of nursing um
and i started to feel
like guilty for not reporting it because
um
i began to
like realize how dangerous some of the
behaviors were of the people in telford
um i'd kind of was learning that it
wasn't
all my fault um like i'd thought it was
so um i went back to
essex police
and i'd said like i want to report
i've reported a rate before but i want
to report it again because i wasn't
satisfied with the result at the time um
and a load of other things happened
afterwards and that's how i kind of saw
it and that's how i kind of worded it um
because i blamed like i put a lot of
blame on the first rape for um the rest
of my behavior afterwards because i felt
like if i hadn't been raped
then i wouldn't have
been so easy with the other guys um
some of the names that i'd mentioned
were men that were already being
investigated for other sexual offenses
that brought
about three court cases um
and um two of them were found guilty and
one man was found not guilty um
um
but i i am still kind of see that as a
as a victory because at least like
i was really glad that um
when shamil was found guilty because he
was i felt like he was a catalyst for
everything else and like
if the if it if a jury agreed that like
he'd raped me the first time
um and that was the first rape then that
kind of made me feel a bit better about
everything else that happened because
i know that like psychologically i was
in a bad place
so
um it was that what that particular
court case was really important to me
um and he was found guilty of like all
counts
uh that meant that he would be in prison
um for at least the next nine years
because he had already he was already
serving another sentence so um
it it added time onto his sentence
it's been longer now
it's been longer than 10 years and he is
still in prison at the moment
um so
it has like made it made a difference
and it has hopefully protected other
other people from him
i told my story to um it's called the
national referral mechanism
for victims of modern day slavery
and they agreed that
what happened to me in birmingham
was considered modern day slavery
um
so
i i i get a
i get a certain amount of funding for
um psychological support because of that
um
and
i you know i regularly had thoughts in
my head at the time that like
i'm basically a free prostitute like i
basically
perform a service for free
and that's basically
what i do and
i think those
thoughts in my head were warning signs
that
um that i was a slave and i was acting
as a slave at the time
how are you now
um i'm actually in a good place now you
know i i qualified um as a nurse um and
i qualified in 2012 so i've been a nurse
officially for 10 years
um
i um
really value um my
um
i guess like now i i value my experience
don't want to say in a negative way but
like at least it like it helps me
help other people
mentally i've had them i've had therapy
which i think really helps um and i'd
encourage anybody else um
to to get therapy if they are struggling
like with things like their own
behaviors or you know they wonder a lot
why they do things um
and um sometimes people think that
talking to someone
won't
help them but actually um
it it does help
it helps to like
translate into
language
how you feel
um also um
therapists can like teach you techniques
to help you cope
if it's one thing that like i could want
that i'd want to like tell other people
is like that you can actually get here
like and i actually had as little
self-respect and self-belief and like
self-worth as
anyone um
who was in my situation would have
i couldn't see the future and i didn't
think there was a future um and so i am
like
ultimately like blown away that like i'm
actually fine
i actually got here so i just want to
you know i just want other
other people to know who are going
through like really bad time at the
moment they've got no belief in
themselves that actually there is
something to look forward to and even if
you can't
see
what's ahead of you
just
um
hope for the best
and um something good will come
he looked young he did look young but it
was after the marriage that i knew that
he was twice my age so i was 15 he was
30. i knew i knew who was going to rape
me and that's what happened and it
became like every single day